[music playing]
Oh, must be more
than a million dollars.
Aw, shucks.
There's more than
$1,000, I betcha.
But how can we
take it with us?
[machinery whirring]
Get outta here!
[squeaking]
Make way!
[squawking]
And me wants peace and quiet.
I've been a bad boy.
I should have
listened to my mother.
[music playing]
But gosh, how can we get home?
Worry, worry, worry, worry.
I got it.
SINGERS: [inaudible].
Yo ho, my land a-ho.
See [inaudible] lands and
raise your hands upon the sea.
And every day when I'm
away, she'll long for me.
And whisper low when tempests
blow [inaudible] and sea.
Yo ho, land ho, land ho.
The harbor's past, the
wind is wild and free.
Yo ho, we go across the sea.
As long as we can
say [inaudible],,
so here's a [inaudible].